as far as supermassive black holes go  Sagittarius a star is actually still  kind of in the minor leagues it's small  but it's not done yet it's still eating  it's still growing  and in around four billion years it's  going to become 25 times larger because  it's going to be eaten by its neighbor  the giant Andromeda galaxy is heading  our way and it's going to engulf our  Milky Way when galaxies merged their  central supermassive black holes merge  and paramitas huge supermassive black  hole will drag Sagittarius a star into  orbit  gradually drawing it closer and closer  until it devours it  the new supermassive black hole will  weigh around 100 million solar masses  but the disruption to the new galaxy  will provide the new supermassive black  hole with plenty to eat and the  opportunity to grow a whole lot bigger  you